wurmlöcher ist die reise durch sie
tatsächlich möglich unterwasserstadt vor
der insel zakynthos und neukloster
aufnahmen vom pluto das sind drei der
fünf themen in den krieg zum top five
news jetzt mücken per post letzte woche
haben wir darüber berichtet dass uns
eine riesige mückenplage bevorsteht der
ranzen mücken horror der deutschen
wildtier stiftung zufolge erwartet uns
in den kommenden tagen und wochen dank
der wetterbedingungen eine sehr hohe
anzahl von mücken und jetzt sind wir
gefragt forscher des leibniz zentrums
für agrarlandschaftsforschung abgekürzt
xss bitten alle deutschen mücken per
post in ein forschungslabor
einzuschicken und das ist der grund
zitat durch die in europa in den letzten
jahren zunehmenden aussprüche von durch
stechmücken übertragenen krankheiten wie
dengue west nil oder schicken boomjahr
fieber sowie den jüngsten kicker virus
ausbruch in südamerika wurde die
aktuelle bedeutung von stechmücken als
krankheitsüberträger unter beweis
gestellt zur risikoabschätzung benötigen
wir dringend daten zur verbreitung der
in deutschland vorkommenden invasiven
und einheimischen arten so die
wissenschaftlerin
turin walter kleine info noch für die
die die forscher unterstützen wollen die
mücken dürfen nicht platt gemacht werden
sie sollte er in einer tiefkühltruhe
abgetötet dann in eine schachtel
verpackt und dann zusammen mit den infos
über den herkunftsort eingeschickt
werden
falls ihr auch mücken einschicken wollt
wir haben die infos dazu hier unten im
infotext neuer höhenrekord in den tropen
auf der erde gibt es eine zählung
zufolge rund 30 4 millionen bäume und
ein paar davon sind etwas besonderes wie
der jetzt entdeckte baum der jlo mehr
anti diese holzart wird industriell zur
herstellung von möbeln und sperrholz
verarbeitet wissenschaftler der
university of cambridge haben im
nordosten der insel borneo einen
zwischen 88 und 91 meter hohen
tropenbaum gefunden warum gibt es keine
genaue angabe der höhe der baum steht an
einer neigung in je nachdem wo man die
messungen an setzt kommen
unterschiedliche werte aus neben dem
dass der baum an einem abschüssigen
gelände steht hatte der vermesser mit
natürlichen
einen zu kämpfen zitat oben angekommen
konnte ich nicht einmal schöne fotos
machen weil ich von einem adler
attackiert wurde und außerdem jede menge
bienen um mich herum schritten so der
leidtragende klettere was macht den baum
der yellow meranti art jetzt aber so
speziell der yellow meranti der steht
erstens auf der roten liste der
bedrohten arten und zweitens gab es
bisher keinen derartig hohen baum der
jetzt gefundene riese übertrifft den
letzten rekord um fast zwei meter und
ist damit in etwa so hoch wie der
glockenturm mit dem big ben in london
und der größte baum der truppen
mammutbäume in nordamerika können
übrigens eine höhe von 115 metern
erreichen so riesig der gefundene baum
ist so gesund scheint auch zu sein zitat
diese giganten zu erhalten ist enorm
wichtig denn sie sind für die gesundheit
und ökologie der wälder von großer
bedeutung gerade hat diese regierung
beschlossen mehr für den schutz und den
wiederaufbau abgeholzter regionen rund
um das becken schutzgebiet zu tun es ist
aufregend zu sehen dass die baumriesen
in nächster nähe zu diesem projekt
vorkommen und es ihnen offensichtlich
gut geht so die forscher rätsel der
unterwasserstadt vor der insel zakynthos
ist gelöst spricht man von einer
unterwasser stadt da denken viele direkt
an den vom plattform aufgesetzt mythos
über die stadt atlantis aber weiß
vielleicht gibt es ja doch zumindest die
reste heute geht es aber nicht um diese
sondern um einen anderen mythos
archäologen haben im fachmagazin marin
and petroleum geology ein solches
unterwasserstadt rätsel aufklären können
die stadt liegt vor der griechischen
insel zakynthos und zeichnet sich durch
seltsame gesteinsstrukturen und nahezu
perfekt gepflasterte wege aus eine sache
jedoch fehlt seit der entdeckung der
stadt zitat seltsamerweise wurden keine
weiteren spuren des lebens gefunden wie
beispielsweise töpferwaren berichtet
julie andrews von der university of east
anglia bei einem weiteren tauchgang
wurde das rätsel um die fehlende
elemente allerdings gelöst das alter der
städte könnte konnte ungefähr auf fünf
millionen jahre datiert werden und kann
somit nicht von menschenhand erbaut
worden seien sämtliche struktur waren
von gasquellen und bakterien geformt und
gefestigt worden zitat
die scheiben und donath formen die ein
wenig wie säuren basen aussehen sind
typisch für die mineralisierung in
solchen unterseeischen kohlenwasserstoff
quellen die von bakterien bewirkte auch
oxidation des methans verändert die
chemie im sediment um bildet eine art
natürlichen zement soénius nach diesen
belegen schlossen die forscher ihre
arbeit mit einem schluss humor ab zitat
zusammenfassend lässt sich dies mit dem
spruch nicht alles ist gold was glänzt
oder in diesem falle nicht jede säule
mehr ist gleich eine antiquität zitat
ende
neue close up aufnahmen vom pluto di
sondrio rey sind sorgt mal wieder für
sensationelle schlagzeilen es ist noch
gar nicht so lange her dass die sonde
erstmals hochauflösende bilder aus der
bisherig geringsten entfernung vom pluto
schießen konnte
jetzt veröffentlichte die nasa ein video
mit neuen close up aufnahme auf den
aufnahmen kann man die vielfältige
topographie des verplanten erkennen aber
seht selbst
überleben wir ein wurmloch also können
wir durch ein wurmloch reisen forscher
der universität lissabon halten diese
erstmals absurd klingende reise durch
ein wurmloch für möglich was aber ist
ein wurmloch ein wurmloch ist ein
abstrakter raum zeit kommender trichter
der in der theorie entsteht wenn zwei
schwarze löcher durch einen im zentrum
jeden loches existenten tunnel
miteinander verbunden sind diese
verbindung wird ein stein hosen brücke
genannt in der praxis werden die
bedingungen für die existenz eines
wurmloch ist aber so speziell dass
forscher noch immer zweifel hegen
obwohl löcher jemals zu finden sein
werden ein stein zufolge soll es sie
aber geben und wenn es sie gibt stellt
sich natürlich auch die frage ob ein
mensch eine reise dadurch überleben
würde
wenn wir mal in ein einziges schwarzes
loch fallen würden scheint die antwort
leicht zu sein zitat das schicksal eines
allzu neugierigen beobachters ist es
durch die starken gezeitenkräfte eine
schmerzhafte spaghetti sierung zu
erleben bevor er dann im zentrum eines
schwarzen loches zerstört wird so die
physikerin
denn etwas anders bei einem wurm noch
sei das jedoch anders ein objekt das in
ein wurmloch fällt würde den forschern
zufolge nicht in der zerstörenden
singularität enden neuen berechnungen
nach würden wir uns nur so weit strecken
bis wir durch den tunnel passen und nach
der kurzen passage wieder entspannen
vermeintlich gefährlich wie wurmlöcher
in science fiction romanen oder filmen
wären die echten wurmlöcher gar nicht
was meint ihr würdet ihr euch zu einer
solchen reise freiwillig zur verfügung
stellen und habt ihr schon mal forsch
aktiv mit einsendungen oder ähnlichem
unterstützen wenn ja wie sind eure
erfahrungen damit lasst es mich in den
kommentaren wissen und wenn euch das
video gefallen hat vergesst nicht genau
den daumen nach oben und natürlich ein
kostenloses abo dazu lassen ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran